WhatsApp is one of the largest and most
ubiquitous social media Platforms in the
world with the 2.7 billion monthly
active users and over 100 billion
messages being sent every single day
it's no question that WhatsApp is
extremely successful from a market share
perspective but the same cannot be said
from a financial perspective it's been
nearly 10 years since Facebook bought
WhatsApp but their revenue doesn't quite
match up with their popularity in fact
it's only now that WhatsApp is even
crossing the billion doll Mark in terms
of Revenue put another way WhatsApp only
makes about 40 cents per user per year
for perspective YouTube has a similar
user count of 2.7 billion monthly active
users but YouTube pulls in nearly $30
billion in Revenue per year or over $10
per user per year even Tik Tok a
platform that's not known to have the
most monetizable of demographics is
expected to pull in $1 13 billion this
year but all of that is nothing in
comparison to the true king of social
media monetization whatsapp's younger
brother Instagram in 2023 Instagram is
expected to pull in $50 billion or over
$20 per user for those of you who
haven't been keeping track that's over
50 times more per user per year than
WhatsApp and that's not too surprising
the reality is that it's quite hard to
monetize a free to use messaging
platform and believe me it it's not due
to a lack of effort over the years
Facebook has tried strategy after
strategy but all of them end up falling
flat because of the tricky game they're
trying to play they don't want to turn
away users by making the platform paid
or by showing ads but at the same time
the platform does eventually have to
make money one way or another and this
pressure has been cranked up to the max
with the high interest and high
inflation environment where investors
expect companies to take a step back
from growth and really focus in on
profit profitability so what really is
the long-term Financial play with
WhatsApp and will WhatsApp ever be a
lucrative
business taking a look back WhatsApp
struggle to monetize can be traced all
the way back to day one in 2009 from the
very beginning WhatsApp was kept afloat
by investors first it was the founders
friends from Yahoo who agreed to invest
$250,000 to get the company going then
it was 8 million from seoa and then
another 50 million also from seoa the
only way that WhatsApp made money was by
charging users $1 per year but that was
mainly just to cover the cost of
verification texts so the actual cost of
running the platform and paying
Engineers had to come out of pocket
WhatsApp was likely hoping that a lot of
these Financial concerns could be
addressed by scale but scale only made
things worse in fact by the time that
Facebook got involved WhatsApp had
already reached 400 million active users
in the first half of 2014 however these
400 million users only translated to a
mere $15.9 Million worth of Revenue
while their bottom line stood at wait
for it
2325 million in other words WhatsApp was
burning nearly half a billion dollar per
year with 400 million users if these
losses were to scale to their current
size WhatsApp would be burning over $3
billion per year clearly the only way to
make such a business viable was to get
the help of a tech giant like Google or
Facebook that could eat up the losses
and that's why WhatsApp would eventually
be sold to Facebook with the help of
Facebook you would think that whatsapp's
financial situation would get better but
the exact opposite actually happened
WhatsApp no longer had to worry about
staying afloat and operational but this
simultaneously made Revenue generation
even less of a concern in fact Facebook
not only neglected generating more
Revenue with WhatsApp but they straight
up undid Revenue generation efforts that
were already in
place kicking off 2016 Facebook would
drop whatsapp's annual $1 fee while also
promising to stay ad free why you ask
well the official reasoning is that
WhatsApp wanted users who didn't have a
debit or credit card to be able to stay
in contact with their family reading
between the lines though WhatsApp
basically saw the $1 fee as a barrier to
gaining market share and utter market
dominance so they dropped the fee
financially speaking though this move
was rather questionable for a few
reasons first of all it's only $1 per
year and I think that virtually everyone
in the entire world would agree that
that's a reasonable fee for a meshing
platform that they use on a daily basis
second of all avoiding the annual fee
was already quite easy so users who
really didn't want to or couldn't pay
didn't have to and third of all WhatsApp
had already brought down the cost of
messaging by hundreds of fold in fact
Forbes estimates that between 2012 and
2018 free messaging services like
WhatsApp and Skype had lost the
Telecommunications industry a total of
$386
billion at the time such Services had a
combined user count of about 2 billion
people so according to this estimate
these Services were saving users on
average $32 per year considering this
even charging $10 per user per year
would have been reasonable much less $1
per year and this would have completely
changed the trajectory of the business
even at $1 per year WhatsApp would have
crossed the billion dollar Mark in terms
of expected Revenue way back in 2015 and
if they eventually incremented this to
$2 per year and then $3 per year it's
quite possible that WhatsApp would be
pulling in north of 101 10 billion per
year in Revenue today but Facebook would
end up choosing growth over everything
else it's possible that Facebook was
thinking that they could use data
collection as a way to monetize WhatsApp
but this led to a whole another slw of
issues kicking off in May of 2017 the
European commission would find WhatsApp
$122 million it turns out that WhatsApp
was sharing user data such as phone
numbers with Facebook in order to
retarget these users with Facebook ads
the however was the least of Facebook's
worries whatsapp's Founders started to
fear that this was the new direction of
WhatsApp and as a result they would both
quit within the next year leaving over a
billion dollars on the table to do so
one of the founders would actually go on
to create a rival nonprofit messaging
platform and that's what turned out to
be signal at least with the founders
gone though Facebook could now roll out
Shady monetization strategies with less
resistance or at least that's what they
thought until they caught up in an even
bigger situation in 2018 Facebook would
get caught up with the Cambridge
analytica Scandal the largest social
media Scandal of all time if you're not
familiar with this Scandal Facebook was
basically involved in a shady data
collection effort that may have
influenced the 2016 presidential
election Facebook would end up having to
pay a $5 billion fine the largest
privacy related fine in history by a
full magnitude while Facebook was able
to forth Define their public reputation
was permanently damaged and the last
thing they wanted to do with WhatsApp
was create some sort of movement against
themselves by implementing some sort of
shady monetization strategy so Facebook
would lay low when it came to Whatsapp
monetization over the next few years
leading us to their current monetization
crisis Facebook would eventually come
out with a rather creative Avenue to
monetize users indirectly while also
remaining ethical and that Avenue was
WhatsApp business WhatsApp business
launched at the beginning of 2018 as a
way for businesses to leverage the
infrastructure of WhatsApp the way it
works is that businesses can use the
WhatsApp business app or whatsapp's
business apis in order to communicate
with customers on a familiar platform
the first 1,000 conversations every
month are free but after that businesses
have to pay for every conversation this
is primarily how WhatsApp has been
generating Revenue over the past couple
of years and Zuckerberg is optimistic
that WhatsApp business is the future of
WhatsApp and it very well could be
WhatsApp business could be the feature
that takes WhatsApp from what is at best
a break even business and turn it into a
lucrative business but with that being
said this still neglects monetizing the
bread and butter of WhatsApp
peer-to-peer communication and to be
honest I don't think this will ever
change the reality is that if Facebook
wants to continue growing whatsapp's
user base they cannot make any sort of
strong monetization effort why well
because the main competition for
WhatsApp is now completely different
when WhatsApp launched the main
competition was regular old SMS texting
and expensive phone plans so when
WhatsApp offered a cheap alternative
people ate it up today whatsapp's main
competition is no longer phone plans
their main competition is Apple and more
specifically iMessage now hearing that
you might be saying that iPhone users
are only a fraction of the global
smartphone market and that Android is
the dominant player but here's the thing
Western iPhone users are the only people
who don't yet already use WhatsApp
everywhere else is already literally
100% saturated by WhatsApp and I'm not
even exaggerating in Brazil whatsapp's
market share is
98.9% in India their market share is
97.1% % in Italy it's 97% and it's the
same way basically everywhere else other
than a few exceptions these exceptions
include Australia Sweden the United
States Canada and France where
whatsapp's market share hovers in the 30
to 40% range you know what else these
countries have in common well these are
the few countries around the world where
Apple dominates in fact in the US Apple
straight up controls the majority with
56% market share and this lines up
almost exactly with whatsapp's 41%
market share within the US and here's
the thing Apple never needs iMessage to
be profitable I'm not even sure how you
would measure the profitability of
iMessage from their perspective iMessage
is simply one facet that sells their
actual product which is the iPhone
experience so they have zero ulterior
motives when it comes to iMessage it's
in their best interest to keep iMessage
as great as possible for free and that's
what what's WhatApp is having to go up
against when it comes to privacy Centric
iPhone users whatsapp's association with
Facebook itself takes them down a Peg
and if you combine this with some sort
of pay wall or Shady monetization
strategy you basically give up all
chances of converting these customers
but let's even forget about acquiring
new users with Android bleeding market
share globally WhatsApp has to make sure
that they don't end up bleeding users
time message and all of this leaves
WhatsApp in a rather sticky situation
they've sacrificed revenue and a profit
over the past decade just so that they
can maximize market share and eventually
monetize but now that they're on the
other side it turns out that they have
to continue this Arrangement if they
want to protect their market share and
instead of monetizing that main consumer
use of their platform they're having to
monetize business use of their platform
but with all of that being said maybe
that's not such a bad thing unlike
Facebook as a whole which has very much
gone bloated WhatsApp has always always
been a pretty lean business probably
because WhatsApp never generated all
that much revenue in fact WhatsApp only
needed 50 Engineers to reach 900 million
users so it's likely that whatsapp's
engineering team is still only in the
low triple digits so WhatsApp doesn't
need to make it billions and billions of
dollars to remain self-sustainable or
worth pursuing in the end WhatsApp may
never become a cash cow for meta but
that doesn't stop WhatsApp from carrying
on The Meta name keeping the company
relevant and earning them some Goodwill
which is all definitely valuable clearly
Facebook has yet to figure out how to
monetize whatsapp's massive user base
but something that they have figured out
is how to monetize their $61 billion
cash reserves with the help of high
yielding treasury bills and bonds with
historically High interest rates the
appeal of bills and bonds is higher than
ever yet traditional brokerages haven't
really adapted with the times they still
expect people to use clunky B Bond
tables scroll through long overwhelming
lists and even use Virtual keyboards
till recently and that's why we created
our own modern Bond platform Silo at
Silo we prioritize the user experience
and the ease of finding an investing in
the issuers you know and trust so that
you too can easily lock in high yields
also choosing a strong user experience
does not mean sacrificing unsafety every
Salo account is ensured by $500,000 in
sip insurance and a $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experienced managing $373
billion worth of assets over the past 45
years so if you're looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below one social media that actually
secretly makes a bunch of money is
LinkedIn check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm hry and I'll see
you guys on the next
one